[Music]
hey welcome to everyday I'm gay Moulson
beard Canada's something called the
Hydra whoo to make something that
they're calling weed beer that's right
it's marijuana infused alcohol doesn't
need to exist
well but it does okay well we before we
get into that I mean that's your topic
Aynsley could you share that photo so I
want to take all right so we're gonna
get to read beer in a second but first
as you all know the rock is the only
Instagram celebrity that I follow I
mostly follow my friends and family and
then I also follow the rock and over the
weekend the rock posted this photo of
him at the Georgia Aquarium and I know
he's giving this blue girl happy
he's like inches away from punching out
this way there's so much wrong with this
picture
and also they have very similar heads
well you know I just love the rock want
to make it clear I'm not advocating the
use of drugs and but if someone were to
have had this weed beer perhaps a photo
like this they would find amusing I
don't know this is really confusing
found my next co-star just look at this
beautiful animal with staggering
intelligence and the beluga whale looks
awesome too oh he's saying that he's an
animal
I'm Jordan let's talk about weed beer
yeah should this is this it should exist
I think we need speech dosed in a better
way and if there's like one for one like
oh this is it'll get you messed up like
a beer will and that's great because
otherwise like you don't know what
you're getting weed weed that's a great
point yes yeah thanks Ryan
see I don't know fine if they start
serving it I don't know if I'll tell the
difference because I'll be like oh this
tastes like it has a ton of hops in
it it smells so bad it tastes bad too
that's why I think it's like terrible
idea I don't like the way beer taste I
like the way we taste this is just a
shitty idea heroin it is no I also think
it's it's as making people tired I also
go to a sleepy bar
it's like goofily do I do sounds bad I
like those bars that there's no TV and
everyone's like it's kind of dark and I
will just stay home maybe my dog know
what that's a better idea there's a bar
I haven't been to but burp castle and
that youthful edge has anybody been
there
it's called bird paps burp castle which
is like very silly but it's super quiet
and they're like shush you if you're
being too loud whatever bringing up know
what a bar if you're not speaking you're
talking but you're not talking like
normally in a bar it's I don't I don't
understand bars okay because it's so
loud yep but you're supposed to be I
understand if you're like there to hook
up with someone a hundred percent do you
know that song a club is a bad place to
find love so the bar is where I go okay
yeah point no but I think we'd beers
gonna be better because people will be
quieter it's gonna lead to quieter bars
I'm off for a week yep see it runs in my
family my brother nice we'd fall asleep
at bars very easily like if they're like
you're so brave yeah I know I'm yeah I
know but there if there were too many
boosts at a bar if it's too quiet even
if it's very loud it's sleepy time so
I'm just saying I don't think this is we
should you it's not good I feel safe
you're saying that maybe we shouldn't be
making like beer Felipe at bars
and it's saying it's making you more
sleepy so why would you want that at a
bar so maybe it's a nice thing to have
at your home have a nice sleepy weed
beer at your home I'm not advocating the
use of it but beware it's designed for
back in my day I've made weed see
multiple times I'd sweetie yeah it's
very but I would not advocate going to a
bar filled with people to relax that
form of that's creepy
I don't quiet bars should quiet people
go to quiet bars now people and also how
do you know it's the right dosage for
beer because every person is different
yeah well every person is different but
a beer will be a liar a beers beer and I
think that's what this company is trying
to do a dummy was a dummy Jordans no
gummy is not kids aren't satisfied with
one gummy never a handful is a gummy
bear
I mean when I give kids beer they only
drink one I don't like that they are
serving these in bars because the beer
actually does really smell bad it has
like such a pungent weed smell and it's
like a total marketing grab to me it's
like look what we did but it like you're
gonna run it through your bar lines and
then every beer that you ever pour after
that it's going to taste like terrible I
did it's not great imagine throwing up
we'd be
[Laughter]
okay so before you think about trying
this weed beer imagine throwing it up
like Hannah says and then stay if you
still want to I think
Natasha I think we have a yes so last
week we had a Mission Impossible episode
and we asked the YouTube community who
should be the next Ethan Hunt and this
is just the the random comment I happen
to find Rafael said Natasha five
exclamation points prayer emoji you just
chose that one around and I just chose
it at random I kind of fell on that one
so Rafael truly thank you so much we're
gonna do something else right now
[Music]
epiphany a moment when you suddenly
become conscious of something that is
very important they told us had tools
equal unemployment tattoos won't stop me
from working at all
but I still prefer my doctor not to have
a face tan
[Music]
welcome to learning and burn in a
segment where I eat something real hot
and then learn something and with me as
always is real life doctor of sociology
Nate PhD Dern hello that's right Ryan
today's burn which comes to us from
youtube user Gisela K is wasabi Natasha
I present the wasabi
and today's learn is hype known tree Mia
what's that you'll learn all right so
now I got to eat this how this works is
that you will eat the wasabi and then
you will read what is on this card when
I hand it to you I will then ask you a
series of questions and only once you
answer them all correctly will Natasha
provide you with the soothing relief of
not milk today but soda because we
learned that bubbles are better for
wasabi I've never had this stuff Oh baby
at all
wait what the app it's gonna clear your
sinuses make a little poopy on your hand
like a poopy on your hand will this kill
me no we looked it up you'd have to eat
a lot more to hear you do you think I'm
allergic maybe a little too much okay
this looks wait oh my god alright
because one person on the internet wrote
I should do this I'm about to put this
in my mouth all right here we go is a
low sodium level in the blood
sometimes caused by the intake of too
much water hole oh my god my nose mild
symptoms included ability to think
headaches nausea and poor balance with a
severe symptoms include confusion
seizures and coma mm-hmm testimony that
doctors as much as 10% endurance
athletes suffer from some form of hypo
to smeltery Mia the doctor recommends
two litres or eight by eight ounces can
be exceeded all right Ryan in a way that
a grandpa would understand what is
hyponatremia it's like a it's in your
blood
uh-huh what happens there's too many
I've it's too much acid
holy severe symptoms include
confuse you get but you can't think low
sodium low sodium from bringing too much
so your homeostasis is off right what is
homeostasis homeostasis is like normal
normalcy
yes that's right Ryan does - in the
treatment mean your sodium levels are
too low or too high low that's right and
so to treat it but you need would you
should you take in salt pills or drink
more water
last question Ryan urban dictionary
defines swallow the urban dictionary
defines thirsty as too eager to get
something especially sexual play Ryan
why are you so thirsty nobody's knowing
I want to have sex and no one will have
sex Natasha please provide the sourdough
oh Jesus
nice job right it's just like a the
peppers okay so this like is hot and
then it goes in your nose and then like
stays there and it burns in your eyes
water and that's bad and now my stomach
feels really bad that I swallowed it but
with the pepper it gets like
increasingly hot and then you breathe
and then it's hot even hotter and so now
like when I breathe I don't feel it but
then like if I like no that wasn't good
that's the difference right there on
every damn day
[Music]
you